foreign
[Music]
hello everyone thanks for coming it's
the third day of next my voice is
Extremely Loud if you learn one thing
learn that nervous and excited feel the
same in your body so I don't know how I
feel right now but it's a mix of those
two so thanks for coming today we're
going to talk about API ecosystems and
generative AI to things that are very
exciting to me my name is Todd this is a
gigantic picture of me
um
I work at Google I'm an engineer
I work on a few different products
including apogee and application
integration so I'm going to be talking
about those a bit today as well
before Google I worked at Twitter and
Microsoft for a long time lots of
dealing with
um with apis
so today's agenda like I said we're
going to talk about API management
generative AI
talk about what apogee does and then
we're going to talk about what apogee is
going to be doing there are some really
exciting things that we're announcing
there's a very large team of
hard-working
product engineers and product managers
and all sorts of great googlers working
on making a preview available you're
going to be able to sign up for that
preview today and it will be available
to trusted testers shortly I'm going to
do something exciting slash nervous
today I'm going to do some extremely
live demos and so like 50 50 it's going
to go perfectly if it doesn't it's
because it's extremely live I'm going to
try to not use the recorded versions of
them there's going to be some demos with
apogee with duet AI we're also going to
have a demo today with chatgpt so we're
really taking some big swings here
so first of all apis apis power digital
interactions so
your phone has an app you're ordering
coffee you're doing a banking
transaction you're replying to a work
email you're on your corporate
environment you're using an internal
application all of these are powered by
apis and there's a tremendous amount of
API growth we've seen so this statistic
here in this 201 average growth rate in
apis this was as of January 2022 so we
see this continue to accelerate
and building apis deploying apis
managing apis governing apis uh oops
wrong direction requires a lot of love
it requires a lot of roles I've broken
them into roughly three personas those
who build the apis those who operate the
apis and those who govern the apis I've
personally worked on like worn all three
of these hats and in truth there's more
hats than these you'll see lots of
diagrams online for full life cycle API
management and income this is lots and
lots of tasks but I want to talk about
three particular ones
so for folks who are building apis
their focus is typically to bring value
to their business to provide
functionality to their end users and in
that you need to design a good API
contract it needs to be available in a
protocol that's useful to your to your
consumers whether they're client
applications or a web browser
um
there's all sorts of architect
architectures you can choose from all
sorts of back-end Services you can build
you can
oop okay I went out for a second uh you
can build serverless functions you can
build kubernetes functions everyone has
a legacy functions and services and
databases hiding in a in a in a Cellar
somewhere in those exists and it's a lot
of work to to build the apis and
typically the folks who are building the
apis are not necessarily the ones who
are governing the apis so if I'm
building an API I want a new piece of
functionality available on my website I
want a new piece of functionality
available in my app I'm not so worried
about governance whereas the governance
people
have a different problem they are very
very interested in governance and
they're less interested I think in the
functionality they want to make sure
that hey is this API properly authorized
is it properly authenticated is it
properly logged is it properly compliant
with country a b c d and e that all have
different regulations that change on a
daily basis so there tends to be
problems when you have your people
developing the apis having to keep up
with all of the governance requirements
for your company and for regulations all
over the world so you'll have your
secure excuse me your security
administrators your your legal teams
sometimes these are all the same person
and one other thing if you have apis you
have all of these steps
even if you don't staff them even if you
don't do anything about them uh
so with documentation with protecting
the apis if you don't protect the apis
then your protection policy is is
free-for-all if you don't secure well I
talked about secure if you're not
analyzing the apis then you know that's
what you've decided to do so you can do
all of these steps with humans you can
do all of these steps with hopes and
dreams or you can do all of these things
with API management tools and software
and processes
and then last is operate so
um typically people operate their apis
need to make sure that they're available
need to scale the apis need to roll out
new versions of the software new
versions of the contracts a lot of the
people here they care about the the
business value the business problem
that's being solved they also care about
not being paged in the middle of the
night
right so at two in the morning I don't
want to figure out how to scale a
database I don't want to figure out you
know why am I getting a surge of traffic
from this country I want tools that
first of all do it all automatically for
me so I don't have to wake up and do it
but second of all I want tools that help
me do it when I do need to do it we're
also noticing with API growth one of the
statistics we have in here there's a
large increase in abusive traffic and so
abusive traffic could be things like
gigantic DDOS attacks where people spin
up botnets and try to take down your
service for bad reasons there's also
scrapers out there who want to run their
business on top of your business people
who want to attack your apis and get
your data or your customer data there's
a whole lot of work to do there
um let's pivot real quick to to
generative Ai and the types of problems
that it can solve and then we'll talk
about how that applies to API ecosystem
and then we'll do some exciting demos
um so generative AI a lot of what we're
seeing out there is about conversational
apis you can talk to a chatbot you can
talk to Bard you can talk to chat GPT
it's a pretty magical experience people
are building apis that are powered by
things like vertex AI powered by open AI
these apis have traditional API
governance needs they need to be
authorized they need to be authenticated
you're going to want to meter them
you're going to want to monetize them
all of these things again if you have an
API you have a need or you have a
responsibility to do all of these or
ignore these
another thing that we're seeing in
emerging area that we're going to demo
here is extending llms having llms
connected to Applications so that they
can retrieve data from exist from
real-time databases they can get sports
scores they can tell you what the
weather is going to be next week they
can book hotel rooms for you this is
very exciting in this model the new
application is the chatbot and that is
calling the apis for you in an automated
way
another thing we're seeing and this is
where duet is doing a lot of work we
have automatic operators automatic AI
assistants they're helping generate code
for you they're generating config for
you
um they're generating dashboards for you
they're taking away a lot of the
boilerplate toil that we're talking
about and all those little bubbles in
the in the API management space
Also they're becoming more advanced they
can generate parts of your business as
they can create CI CD pipelines and
other things the the last one the one
that's probably most exciting is some
Services don't need to be written
anymore now we can have ai be a service
in the request path right
so in this case I'll take a real easy
example let's say that you want to
return your payload as Jason and all of
the data is coming to you from your back
end in XML there's all sorts of
libraries that do this but if the
libraries like this didn't exist you
could in theory just ask an llm hey
convert this blob from Jason to XML and
it would do it for you you don't have to
write a complicated Library there are
lots and lots of examples of this where
the llm can actually be the last mile
service in your infrastructure all of
these are
are pretty exciting what we see
generative AI doing is that for all of
these personas build operate govern with
all the subtasks analyze monetize secure
authorize you have a set of of different
people who have different jobs to do and
there's a gradient of skill some are new
to the area they're going to have to
learn they can't do anything some are
novices and can do certain tasks some
are experts and have been working on it
for years gender of AI is going to help
all of these people move up maybe more
than one level maybe multiple levels so
especially for people who are more to
the left in this diagram who don't
necessarily know how to get started with
a technology general of AI is going to
help them get started or solve specific
problems in a compliant way and then for
the experts it's going to help automate
tasks and it's going to help bring more
things together
our hypothesis over in Google is that
we're already seeing massive API growth
that's been going on for decades I think
the last
two decades or so you've seen a lot of
especially with the internet and then
application stores on the on the phones
Etc you've seen this massive growth and
we were talking about 200 percent year
over year AI is soon going to be
creating apis as mashups of existing
apis it's going to be discovering apis
Etc but we think
click we think this is what's going to
happen that 200 percent is going to look
a lot larger and I'm unwilling to put a
number on it because I don't know
exactly what that number would be
so let's talk a little bit about API
management and then we'll get to some
cool demos so Google has a full
lifecycle API management product it's
called apogee uh
it supports most of those functions that
you see in the bubbles it will help you
document apis it'll help you secure apis
monetize apis authenticate apis it will
do all of these with tools instead of
humans right so if your core competency
in your company is API management that's
great there's a lot of work for you to
do if your core competency is building
software for your business you probably
don't want to spend lots and lots of
time doing API management tasks with
with human toil right so this is what we
call shifting down so instead of doing
so there's the concept of Shifting left
doing things earlier in your development
cycle shifting down is really
Outsourcing some of the required
steps in whatever tasks you're doing to
somebody else to software to a set of
tools and that's what apogee helps doing
apogee has all sorts of functionality
that's run out of gcp and then it has a
data plane that runs in your cloud of
choice modern companies modern
technology Stacks or multi-cloud or
hybrid Cloud our hybrid multi-cloud and
apogee supports all of these things it's
a variety of use cases a variety of
scale software as a service platform as
a service is a is a great thing for
helping you shift down and then we have
tools that support a variety of
different personas so developers
security administrators
data analysts like the data coming into
apogee can be made available in looker
all sorts of things to help power your
business so now I'm going to talk about
where apogee is going
so apogee
is investing now in tools to help you
with this explosion of apis that's
coming
this explosion of new apis is going to
create a massive amount of toil
is going to create a large amount of
risk and interestingly enough we think
AI is also going to help provide the
tools to tame this wild sprawl of apis
that are out there so we're going to
talk about a few things today in the
demos we're going to help the developers
build with ease especially the things
that the developers don't necessarily
want to do that are difficult to do that
are not necessarily writing the code for
the business logic managing the supply
chain understanding where the the
services live where the data lives
combining these all together in
compliant ways compliance is a really
big deal especially with the amount of
regulations all over the world as they
shift and then the last one is we want
to help you protect your apis so that
your your customers and your assets are
secured
Okay so we've approached the
very possibly live vary may not work
demo portion I'm very excited for it not
nervous at all
we're going to start with a fictional
company Cloud9 being in company so
Cloud9 being so I'm from the Seattle
area they wouldn't let me talk only
about the Seahawks because we're in San
Francisco so we're going to talk about
coffee
so they are a fictitious coffee company
that had a single location in Seattle
and became popular and so now they're
expanding they take orders from
supermarkets and from Costco and from
all sorts of from other places this is
fictitious
and they need apis to support this right
now they're receiving all their orders
from phone calls and faxes they're
undergoing digital transformation
they're going to use gcp to to do all of
these things
um
so the first problem that this company
has is so they have a catalog of apis
they want to add new apis all of the
apis have these governance concerns all
of these apis
have part of the API is the contract
that it provides to the application it
wants to be cons when you build a new
API you want it to be usable by your
consumers you want it to be consistent
with your other apis you want it to be
compliant with your policies so here at
our company we have Shiloh who's an API
developer Shiloh needs to create a new
API it's a very good idea to design the
API first before you implement it you
want to make sure that the API is usable
by your consumers so you want to design
it and you want to mock it out before
you actually ship it and have to support
it for the next 10 years or have to
break compatibility by doing it so
Shiloh wants to design the API Shiloh is
a developer so Shiloh is going to use vs
code so let's go into vs code
which I believe is here okay
so
in vs code so first of all we have
apogee now available in vs code where
for Shiloh he's able to see existing
apis that are in his API catalog so this
is pulling live from from gcp data
the exciting thing we're going to do in
here is we're going to help Shiloh
create an API spec
the important part about it is not
just that Shiloh is going to be able to
create an API specification that's in a
specific format that's in open API
format and in yaml and has all of the
required information the very exciting
part is that duet AI understands all of
this context that's in Shiloh's existing
API catalog it's going to hopefully in
the demo generate correct security
schemas it's going to reuse objects from
from his existing catalog so let's go to
the magic wand button and I'm going to
say let's accept
purchase orders oops
I purchase orders for specialized
coffee beans through web API okay
so duet is now generating this open API
specification and we're going to dig
into it in a second once it's finished
loading okay so first of all so we show
the yaml document so Shiloh is a
developer
he is going to want to make changes to
this
um he's not he's not going to want to
use different tools than he's previously
used so name API support
um we'll say coffee API support
over here we have the Swagger renderer
which is showing the open API spec It'll
point out any problems that are in there
we'll also be able to point out problems
in the ammo let's zoom in a little bit
so some of the interesting things here
that I'll show is so there's a purchase
order with a customer ID a purchase
order ID there are items the items that
are in this purchase order are referring
to another schema that exists already so
it it points to something that's already
in Shiloh's inventory or in his catalog
which is called a coffee bean which is
great so the AI didn't have to invent
a new object called a coffee bean it
took it from Shiloh's existing catalog
other things is the duet AI it knows
that Shiloh's company has the following
author authorization flow so it uses
oauth it has two Scopes write and read
and you'll see that for the variety of
apis it will say hey this one uses the
read scope
this one down here uses the right scope
and it does some other interesting
things uh Shiloh's company requires
pagination on certain types of apis
you'll notice when you get the purchase
orders
it um the API is already paginated so
it's not just an arbitrary API that
meets open API specifications it's
actually
fulfilling what Shiloh's company
requires and is useful for the customers
as well let's go ahead and upload this
to
the apogee API Hub so purchase order API
so we're going to create this this is
calling a whole bunch of gcp apis and
we're going to view it in the API hub
all right so here's my API it's now a
concept API that's an open API style
it's for public users it has a support
contact and then we can look at all the
versions that were out there version one
was created just now so
let's go back here so Shiloh
lost his Clicker
bad Shiloh
and has to press the buttons manually so
Shiloh can go from idea to API
specification in minutes in the tools
that he's familiar with which in this
case is vs code
um and then he can upload this to his
catalog and he can continue working from
there
um and then obviously we're going to
want to build more functionality over
time we're going to want to help Shiloh
mock his API and test his API
um and you ship his API and protect his
API
um and all of these things in apogee is
is very Adept at that
I really did lose the clicker sweet
too many pockets okay uh let's go to
another problem over in in Cloud9 coffee
so Emma is an integration specialist so
most of the customers so far have been
faxing in orders or emailing orders in a
in a PDF
and they're going to continue to do that
whether or not they know about these new
apis or or there's a new application
available there's going to be some that
are going to continue to email things in
so Emma wants to build an integration
so this isn't a traditional immediate
real-time API this is Emma wants to
solve a problem where when somebody
emails a purchase order form she wants
to extract all the information from the
purchase order and she wants that to
then fulfill the API where it actually
creates a entry in the purchase order
database
kicks off all sorts of automations to
inform the warehouse etc etc so let's
see what Emma is going to do so uh
Google has a product a great product
called application integration that
helps with this it's a very no code low
code experience
um and from this we're going to use duet
AI to generate
the implementation of this API of this
problem that Emma has automatically on
her behalf and again
um the idea isn't that the AI is going
to be omniscient and do everything
automatically the AI is there to assist
Emma who's still doing the work so let's
take a look at this one
okay
so here we are so Emma is in the Google
Cloud
experience she's has her purchase order
API she's going to create an integration
and let's have her pick
this will be for creating purchase
orders and then I'll auto fill this in
so automate accept orders based on an
incoming PDF okay and again duet in this
case understands the API catalog it
understands also the database
connections and the business processes
and apis that already exist inside
Cloud9
so
we can confirm this
okay and this created
a skeleton of an integration for Emma
which Emma can now review so it says
okay this has a generated name does it
look good to you I'll say it does
created a variable called a purchase
order that seems good and then let's
take a look at what it generated it says
okay we'll trigger when we have a new
order it will get the document from the
input so this is going to be a PDF
document and it's going to call Doc AI
which is a gcp service which is going to
extract structured information from
unstructured data so it's going to
extract the purchase order information
from this PDF
it's going to retrieve the order details
oh it's going to put something in sap I
think the issue here with so sap I don't
think is necessarily the right place I
think Cloud9 they have a bunch of
databases that are just named sap and
netsuite and Salesforce and other things
they don't say this is for purchase or
this is for purchase orders this is for
customers so duet doesn't necessarily
know the exact right one to pick so
Emma's going to do that momentarily
then I want to calculate a delivery date
and I want to send a response to Emma
that response will probably be an email
so let's confirm the skeleton but let's
go ahead and say that yeah sap is not
necessarily the right thing so
let's say let's replace the
recommendation so there's lots of apis
in the catalog there's lots of
connectors and actions that are
available in application integration
duet knows which ones are about
databases which ones are about storing
data and it knows okay if sap is not the
correct one it could be netsuite it
could be Salesforce
Emma should probably create some better
names and call them purchase order
database or employee database things
like that that would help the AI in the
future but Emma was able to do that so
now the automation has been updated
where the order is created in the the
netsuite product
let's look at one other thing let's look
at how is the response being sent what
information are we going to email back
to Emma yeah it looks like we're just
taking the order created information
and we're sending that information to
Emma's output let's take a look at what
that's doing yeah it's just sending it
directly Emma might want to customize
the information that's going back to the
to the customer and data mapping can be
tricky it can it can require a lot of
manual steps and require a lot of
knowledge for for Emma in this scenario
so we're going to have duet help with
this and we're going to say hey I want
to include the delivery date so map
delivery dates from shipment details and
calculate the total order value into the
order output
so we'll apply this modification
and duet will combine these together the
order created shipment details throw it
into the Json composer and send it to
the output
um and so duet did a lot of the work for
Emma Emma is still responsible for for
the business task here so we'll confirm
this we'll go back
okay
so Emma had the specification from
Shiloh
um she knew what the problem was that
she was trying to solve related to
taking PDF documents and duet was able
to help her create these Integrations
the last one
uh is where we're going to talk about
chat bots so llms are trained on this
huge Corpus of data and it takes a long
long time to train them so they're
typically Frozen in time so if you ask
Chachi PT or Bard
um you know what the weather is outside
or what is the stock price of your
company or something like that it's not
necessarily going to know there's an
emerging field right now where you can
actually connect llms via things called
extensions or plugins to your
application
is very exciting but also it's a new
type of application it requires
authentication requires authorization it
requires all of the governance concerns
that are out there so beyond just
creating the plug-in taking your your
API and saying I want to expose this as
a plug-in somewhere you also need it to
be properly protected you need it to be
properly governed you need it to be
properly operated so let's take a look
at how we do this so in this case
there's Billy our Solutions engineer so
Billy has this uh Coffee Bean API that
exists and wants to make it accessible
to both vertex and chat GPT so vertex AI
Google's AI product has support for
extensions coming out soon I believe
that's in private preview chatgpt
already has this out in a public preview
so we're going to look at that
and Billy wants to make sure that
security
authorization logging Etc is all done
correctly
um so and what this will do in this
scenario is make it so that on the cloud
nine being coffee website they could
embed a custom chat bot that you could
talk with and say hey what kind of
coffee do you have I would like to order
coffee place orders manage your orders
Etc so let's take a look
and what we'll do here we're going to
instantly make your API into an llm
extension
all right
now we pray to the demo gods
okay so first we're in Chachi PT and we
say
um like
what is the temperature temperature
in Seattle today and it's going to say I
don't know because I'm an llm
I don't have real-time capabilities
including weather information
please check a reliable weather
connection okay so let's go back here to
our purchase order API and this time
we're going to create an extension
so duet in this so when you create an
extension
there's a whole bunch of scaffolding you
have to put in place you have to
describe the extension to the llm so
that the llm can tune some models or
some classifiers to know when to call
the API you have to provide an open API
specification and then you can
optionally optionally add authentication
and authorization information that
you're definitely going to want to add
so in this demo we're going to choose
chat GPT and we're going to have duet
autofill the information that chatgpt
requires so this is going to be the
Coffee Bean purchase API
I'm going to call this the Coffee Bean
extravaganza
um
and just because it's fun in August
okay
um and duet generated this API lets you
create and manage purchase orders for
specialized coffee beans you can
purchase there
lastly we're going to say there's no
authentication required for Chachi PT
to to call into this API however for
users we're going to require that they
use Google oauth
that will enable us to secure certain
things on the back end and then also if
we choose to make this a per customer
item or if we're going to build
customers for it or need their
information then we can get it from
there so we're going to create this
Plugin or create this extension
okay this if I say
that this generates a manifest that
chatgpt will be able to read so
the way that chat EPT and vertex handle
extensions is different so I believe
that the vertex model is that you upload
something to essentially an extension
store chat GPT you have to go into the
chat GPT UI which we're going to do in a
second and you have to point it at the
Manifest and then you have to update
some tokens so we're going to do that
live
okay so this is named The Coffee Bean
Extravaganza in August
okay and it says we don't have a chat
GPT token so chat GPT requires that for
anything authenticated chat GPT stores
uh your application secrets in its own
database and then gives you a Chachi BT
token that it can use to associate with
your extension so we're gonna go get
that all right now
so first we're going to grab the name of
the extension host we're gonna go to
Chachi PT
and I'm going to go to the plug-in store
and I'm going to develop my own plugin
okay
ooh error manifest
the name for human field is 31
characters long okay we're going to go
back
and we are
not going to call this extravaganza
okay
Coffee Bean purchase API that sounds
great okay so we're going to create this
oh oh I didn't add authentication to it
you can see that it's not there
okay now we're going to secure it with
apogee and Google oauth
okay now it needs the chat GPT token
okay we're going to try this again
develop my own plugin
hey okay so it's the Coffee Bean
purchase API and now it needs the oauth
credentials for my application
so I'm going to go back over here and
I'm going to copy the client ID and I'm
going to give it to chat GPT I'm going
to say here's the client ID I need to
give it a secret
and I'm going to copy the secret and put
it in here
we go next
okay chat GPT is storing this in their
back end and they've generated a token
that I can now use and store in my
manifest
so and they say my open API my open AI
token is this string
I'm going to input that in my extension
I'm going to save it to the Manifest
okay
um
it's now going to show up in here yeah
here's the open AI token so now all the
all of the toil has been done for me and
it's secured let's go back to chat GPT
see if I did that right yep okay do I
want to install this sure why not
okay open a open AI has embedded the
plug-in that's okay
okay it says hey you need to log in you
will be redirected to the coffee beans
purchase API to log in log in with the
purchase API okay so this is doing
Google oauth for me
I'm already logged in with Google oauth
so it's probably not going to show the
screen okay so it says I have this
installed now let's
see if see how Chachi PT and the plugin
work together let's make this larger uh
what types of coffee are available
okay
chat GPT is thinking
oh it's saying I'm using the Coffee Bean
purchase API which is an unverified
plugin
it's calling that and it's saying here
are the types of coffee beans available
Arabica and Robusta and here's what they
are and let's take a look at what
chatgpt actually did so it used this
plugin
and here it says it called the list
coffee beans API
and it said it requested a page of one
with at most ten right because this is a
pagination required API and here's the
response in chat GPT made it very nice
for me
um
let's see how powerful these chat Bots
are with apis and if they can do new
things let's say I want to order
15 units of the dark bitter coffee
okay
chat EPT is using
this again it says your order's been
placed it ordered the Robusta coffee
which is from Vietnam it's dark and
better and it costs 67.50 and if we look
here
it used the create purchase order API
that we designed earlier it says I want
to order 15 of them the Coffee Bean ID
is two it figured out based on the
information that I received from the
coffee from the list coffee beans item
which one corresponded to dark bitter et
cetera et cetera it created order one
two three four five its status is
pending Etc et cetera so this is a new
application a new chat bot that I didn't
have to create all I had to do was give
an API to Chachi PT to vertex AI
configure it appropriately and I want to
make sure it's governed so I have apogee
controlling all of these things
still no clicker oh
good news
the clicker has been located
now the the very last issue that's
happening
um over at Cloud9 mean is they're
becoming extremely extremely popular
um and now they're being attacked
they're being attacked because somebody
bad wants to knock their site offline
somebody wants to place a whole bunch of
orders and then cancel the orders and
cause all sorts of churn and problems
for the company someone's just trying to
do research so the Amari the security
expert at Cloud9 has noticed that the
the new apis are under attack
so
what we have here is Google so also
using Ai and ml this is more traditional
Ai and ml pattern recognition Google as
it turns out gets lots and lots of
traffic Google has lots and lots of apis
we have sites like YouTube and Gmail and
Google search
the millions and billions and trillions
of API calls that have happened to
Google have had many attacks in them and
thousands of Engineers at Google have
built models and built software that can
detect and shield apis from the attacks
so what we've done in apogee is we have
a product called apogee Advanced API
security which uses these models from
Google level traffic data
um it creates ml models for these and it
will identify that the traffic that's
coming through your apigee services does
it correspond to any of these types of
attack patterns that Google has seen in
the past and this is something that's
available now and it's something that
we're continuing to work on over time to
give more capabilities to it and to also
customize it for for your product also
we don't take any of the traffic data
that you are receiving that's going
through apogee and we don't use that to
train any of Google models we don't use
that to train any customer models it's
all your data is your data which is also
the case by the way for all of the duet
demos that we're showing here nothing is
shared back to to use for training
Google models nothing is used for other
customers your data is your data
um and the big message to take away from
this is
your engineering team your legal team
your security team
is typically a fixed size and it takes a
long time to hire people it takes a long
time to ramp people up
um you have a responsibility with all of
your apis to do something for all of
these tasks on the Wheel
and you have three choices you can
fulfill these tasks using humans you can
not fulfill the tasks and hope certain
things don't go wrong or you can shift
down and you can push the responsibility
onto the platform you're running on and
so Google is investing very heavily in
providing tools that do this in an
automatic way for you in a highly
personalized contextual way using your
Enterprise data in a secure and private
way where it doesn't go back to Google
so for all of the demos that I showed
you they're all going to be available to
trusted testers trusted tester program
we want your feedback we want to hear
hey this works great for us or hey this
is not working or we want something
different or we want more functionality
so if you get in the trusted tester
program we're going to want feedback
we're going to want to work with you so
I'm going to thank you in advance for
for signing up and then for joining that
program
[Music]
thank you